they are ready and waiting in a blip
city thought they think is the
inevitable after Homs these people fear
their next on the regime's hit list here
the rebel flag flies in the city center
but the area's surrounded by regime
tanks and military vehicles at the
moment the tanks are outside the city an
ever-present intimidation it lived
citizens believe it's only a matter of
time before they move in an attack and
they have their own army here he said
yes we are human we are not an animal
cheer us like an animal first of all we
are just a human we ask for freedom we
can't have it unless we get a river of
applauds in our country this is
impossible and the UN or anyone do to
help you militia groups
humanity at least sent us a miracle food
something diesel you we have non diesel
in a fuel in this city for a week we are
afraid in the front mascaras Alexa them
are scary in homes here they live in
homes built for escape if the soldiers
arrive there's a labyrinth of alleyways
and holes connecting the houses with
hidden steps leading to rooftops from
where they can run jump and hide for
those mourning their dead this struggle
to have a voice has already cost dear
the family here has lost their son he
was just 14 years old
very criminal 11 mouths suck people
Syrian I don't like Bashar Assad because
very criminal in the basement of houses
across it Lib province they plot and
plan protests uploading pictures of
demonstrations as well as messages of
revolution they're able by using the odd
satellite transmitter which has been
smuggled across the border because most
communications here have been cut we
must show the world our work we take a
video for everything we see every
imagery every injuries every arrested
morale continues to be high here despite
what appears to be mounting odds against
them they're still getting defectors
from the Assad army but so far nowhere
near enough to really take on the
president